the Joe Rogan experience what did you
think about Auto Sonia versus y'all
Romero yeah it's a tricky one you know
what I mean so obviously a lot of people
you know her and I'm not gonna obviously
wasn't the most you know wasn't so many
exchanges and stuff like but I guess
you've got to look at it why that
happened and I think y'all you know
obviously was just sitting there waiting
for for easy to come in every time you
know easy did commit to something he
just come out like he literally was
gonna wait till you come in and I'm just
gonna throw bombs obviously is he knows
that so he's trying to touch him trying
to get him to react and you know you
know waiting for him to explode and
things they just didn't happen and so
was just a tricky one me and that's why
a lot of people don't say whatever but
you're never in there you don't really
know what it feels like to you actually
in there and someone like Romero he can
take care of like that you know what I
mean so yeah I didn't like the criticism
of it there's not much how it's out of
Sun you could have done and yeah well
like I mean I guess he's he's selling
that is he didn't do anything that he
wouldn't fight him man-to-man but that's
not true yeah
because he didn't come forward yeah like
he's he's selling as if he was chasing
Izzy and is he wasn't doing anything but
that's not what happened like is he was
trying to get him to engage and he
didn't want to engage he was literally
standing there at the beginning in the
fight standing still which is kind of
crazy there was that was like a solid
minute or something or landing still and
then he was switch stances a little bit
true
yep stand still shook up a little he but
he's lulling you to sleep and you saw
that when he did land a couple good left
hands yet when is he did try to connect
when he did try to get close chart
bought into it a little bit and yo all
through that [ __ ] left hand yeah
crazy how fast that guy is yeah I mean
so again like you know when you're just
you can sense that as soon as I do
commit to anything he's just gonna come
guns blazing obviously you know fair
enough obviously there's gonna be a lot
more opportunities if he started trying
to do stuff as well but the fact that he
done nothing to lose just ready to
explode it it makes things a how it is
you know if you want to fight smart if
you're trying to find smart as well
you know and he should fight smart and I
think you need smart I think he did I
mean this is what fighting is all about
some fights like
Zhang Wei Li and Yanni on Jay check is
super super exciting but that styles
those dials matched up you mean not
every fight is super exciting robert
whittaker fought Yoel in a very exciting
way but I mean that's a bad way to fight
with that guy yeah you're Welles a
[ __ ] beast just even just hidden him
or even like a I reckon easy from the
leg kicks now obviously that would have
been hurting a Romero but it's probably
hurting yourself kicking him you know I
mean just solid rock he's a solid you
could imagine France stuff and hidden
just a break well it's what Rockhold
said he said every time he hit him and
hurt him well the guy's just he's a
freak man and he's 42 it's like what in
the [ __ ] man crazy absolutely crazy I I
really felt like that was how is he how
to find him
I really didn't think that he could
fight him any other way I mean I've
expected that uses length use his reach
uses attributes stay on the outside use
the he's a higher level kickboxer use
that yeah and try to lure him into you
know attacking and counter those those
attacks but it's one of those things but
it's like if you see like when tyron
woodley fought wonderboy kind of same
thing a lot of people were saying all
those are boring fights well that's how
you have to fight that guy exactly
that's how you fight him and you can
wait on him and you could remember you
know I mean obviously all let's just go
out there let's just be you know really
exciting but you lose ever forget about
you know you're gonna have that sort of
especially if you champion you got it
you gotta fight the father it's gonna
get you to win and you only have so many
holes that can get punched in your card
right those those punch holes are
valuable and you you let yourself get
cracked when you didn't have to there's
no need for that yeah you should always
fight smart it's dangerous enough we'll
fight smart hitting not get hit you know
that's a you know that's that's how I
believe as well you know that's what
it's just Stiles
it's just Stiles the way Stiles matchup
[Applause]